hallo mein name ist luca und wir spielen
heute akinator in minecraft heute am
freitag ist natürlich wo ich kann mich
gar nicht richtig wenn ich sehe ich
komme hier gar nicht weg ich bin
eigentlich heute am freitag ist er bei
mir minecraft tag frei
wir lassen es mit den komischen namen
deswegen habe ich mir gedacht ja was
gefällt euch denn in letzter zeit auf
meinem kanal und das war eindeutig
akinator weil wir da ja auch schon bis
hartenstein jedenfalls haben wir ukulele
auch schon bei akinator gefunden schaut
euch am besten nachdem ihr dieses video
zu ende geschaut hat auch das video von
akinator kollege schaut euch danach
vielleicht alle meine anderen 1500
videos an
hat man das auch geregelt und da habe
ich mal geschaut die gibt sich akinator
in minecraft irgendwie ja gibt es hier
ankommt
diagonal die ab und zu beginn hat
geklappt
das was und im chat ein gewinn entsteht
steht glaube ich da hinten also ist
jammer peaceful also ich sollte ich
vielleicht erst mal ganz kurz erklären
wie das ganze funktioniert es geht nicht
so wie bei akinator darum dass wir uns
irgendwas ausdenken können also sei es
ein kollege sei es konkreter ist eine
wasserflasche seißen star im haus
irgendwas sondern wir können uns hier
wird nicht nur minecraft mops überlegen
die hat dann pickel deswegen nehmen wir
jetzt als mob einfach mal beispielsweise
die fledermaus und schauen mal ob diese
akinator rische hexe die fledermaus
erraten kann ja die fledermaus ist es
voll ist ja ob blogs humor johanna kino
dass ihr mob kommen lee drop übel items
das ist schwierig gerade der normale
minecraft spieler wird sagen hey nein
die fledermaus stopp nichts allerdings
würde ich sagen
die drop erfahrung und erfahrungspunkte
kann man weiter verarbeitet aber das
sind keine items luca genau ich dummkopf
also nein jersey ob lippen motto no dass
ihr mogwai ps dieser akinator zwickt
mich auch komplett wir nehmen jetzt mal
eine cave spyder und zwar ist ja mal
peaceful no das mobile web entitec ich
mein nein so ist ja ob blogs harmon die
not des mobs porn if underground diaz
des ewz das web app anything to the
stone denkt bestimmt einen silberfisch
oder
wir probieren das ganze mit der krebs
beide einfach normal ist immer peaceful
no das interview sollte techno ist im ox
heino des top spot lief underground
jetzt dass im ok du bist download
wieso geht das nicht ich krieg die
ganzheitlich auf und es passiert man es
scheint so als hätte ich tatsächlich
alles zerstört das ist nämlich gerade so
dass dieser button nicht mehr da ist und
sie hier ist auch ich hab mich tief
mitbekommen als ob ich schon wieder die
map zerstört habt was soll denn das
immer mache ich alles kaputt gamer drei
sagt er hier irgendwas okuma dem freunde
hier ist anscheinend glaube ich
irgendwas kaputt gerade oder ich als
minecraft experte kann das natürlich
ganz schnell eben mal korrigieren so hat
aufgehört zu blinken
ob das jetzt gut war weiß ich nicht ich
schaue mal ob sie hinten geklappt hat
und zwar hey lass mich mal die will
nicht sterben ich glaube laden die mir
einfach noch mal neue 2000 jahre später
habe ich jetzt auch endlich die met neu
geladen das heißt wir sind wieder drin
können hier toll auf den schalter
klicken und es geht los und jetzt
entscheiden wir uns für das entscheiden
wir uns hier entscheiden uns mal für
einen guardian also diesen wächter die
unter wasser leben also ist ja mal piece
for death mit nino dankbar gerade wieder
irgend eine komische bewegung dass ihr
mobilisierten tour-tag ich würde sagen
nur weil der konsum strahl an ist ja
blogs highroller gesonnen wie ich würde
sagen nein dass ihr mops porno liv
underground heißt unter wasser
underground ich würde mal sagen nur dass
im open water jetzt guardian u kann es
ja doch noch was sie probieren es jetzt
mal mit einem wolf beziehungsweise einem
hund ist ja mops voll
der ist eigentlich beides ist ja ob
blogs heino das immer kommen die drop
adams
ich meine hunde trocken gar nichts
deswegen jetzt etwas richtig krass und
zwar einen schneemann ist ja mops von
mini es ist ja ob blogs
ich würde ich sag mal einfach jetzt can
you know the witcher faktische der hat
keine ahnung man